and I have to begin by saying the last
thing we wanted is to be where we are
now being interim leader was not the job
I wanted to be doing I wanted ed
miliband to be our prime minister and
for us to be in government we're
bitterly disappointed to have lost so
many Labour MPs in England in Wales and
of course in Scotland but I want to pay
tribute to Ed Miliband he is a
thoroughly decent and principled man who
threw himself into the leadership
unstintingly and he could not have
worked harder or being more committed
and I want to pay tribute to Jim Murphy
he stepped up in Scotland at an
intensely difficult time and he faced
that challenge with energy and
determination and I want to pay tribute
to to all the thousands of party members
and supporters who worked so hard and to
all our fantastic party staff who put
their heart and soul into their work
thank you
the party the party is still very raw
very upset we lost and we lost badly
there's no getting away from that and it
came as a shock we thought we had a
fighting chance of forming the next
government and the ten o'clock exit poll
was a body blow none of us will ever
forget and it took me back to nineteen
ninety-two now we see that 1992 election
as a stepping stone to victory in 1997
but that was not how it looked then then
as now we thought we could win then as
now the polls fueled that thinking and
they were horribly wrong then is now we
fought a good campaign under a leader
with many fine qualities the defeat was
all the more painful because then as now
minutes before the exit poll landed we
thought we were heading into government